eu acho que eu vi quebrar um pouco a
harmonia desse encontro né
eu vim falar de um assunto que é
delicado um assunto que normalmente as
pessoas jogam debaixo do tapete
ninguém quer falar por preconceito e eu
cara de pau tô aqui pra falar com muito
prazer
o disco tem aí os conservadores né
eu vim falar sobre sexualidade e falar
sobre sexualidade já é meio tenso né e
sobre a sexualidade do autista mas penso
ainda é mais difícil porque existe todo
um preconceito em torno disso e porque
existe esse preconceito
eu acredito que o preconceito ele exista
porque na verdade não acreditamos muitas
vezes que o autista e aí também não é só
o autista eu incluo também o portador de
deficiência intelectual principalmente
nós não acreditamos que eles têm uma
identidade sexual é como se eles nascem
sem sexo
então tá tudo bem né no começo está tudo
bem mas depois chega o tal dos hormônios
né na adolescência na pré adolescência
chega os hormônios aí que começa o
problema porque os hormônios não sabem
de nada e eles aparecem assim do nada e
aí começa todo o problema também pro
autista porquê porque ele vai ter que
lidar com alguma coisa ali que a nova
pra ele também
e por que que isso gera tanto problema
pra todo mundo a gente precisa entender
uma coisa o desenvolvimento sexual ele
não acompanha o desenvolvimento
intelectual
por isso que às vezes o autista ele é o
portador deficiente intelectual ele se
mas tudo no ônibus e no metrô na rua e
aí as mães entre em desespero
nossa porque ele faz isso
porque aí muitas ainda fala assim é é
não aprendi a contar até 10 mais isso
ele sabe a gente não tem nada a ver com
ele tenta ver por moniz aí já levei a
barra de todo mundo né
então o que acontece é se o autista ele
tem 15 anos
o portador de deficiência têm 15 anos o
desenvolvimento sexual dele vai ser de
menino de 15 anos mas o intelecto dele
ou a parte do raciocínio lógico dele não
é de 15 anos
então por isso que às vezes eles ficam
meio atrapalhados aí
e qual é a nossa postura diante disso
será que nós vamos impedir a começar
pelas ameaças
vou chamar bicho papão não existe mais
neve potter já se aposentou
vai nascer cabelo nos dedos vai nascer
verruga na na ponta do dedo se você
fizer isso você vai virar lobisomem um
dia o menino entrou no consultório e ele
falou eu toco muito medo eu tenho muito
medo de dormir e acordar lobisomem
porque a minha mãe falou que eu vou
virar lobisomem porque eu tô me
masturbando na boa
então gente é esses preconceitos seja
que tratasse
essa questão com mais delicadeza mais
tranquilidade
eu penso assim ó porquê que é tão
simples quando uma criança quer fazer
cocô a mãe fazia até o banheiro não é
que todo mundo aprende a sair fazer cocô
no banheiro xixi no banheiro só papo no
banheiro mas quando se fala de
masturbação ninguém manda banheiro que é
cortar a mão ea xingar que falar que é
sem vergonha então gente se a gente
tratar com naturalidade o assunto
vocês também vou dizer a mesma coisa vai
pro banheiro no banheiro que você faz
isso agora sem ninguém ensina é aquela
questão do desenvolvimento intelectual
ele não tem o raciocínio lógico ele vai
fazer aonde dá vontade seria a mesma
coisa se
nossos pais ou seja lá quem for não
tivesse ensinado a gente a fazer xixi
pouco no banheiro
eu poderia simplesmente dizer assim
gente tô meio apertado fazer xixi
sozinho aqui quando eu falo
espero incomodar ninguém mas eu aprendi
que não é assim
aí eu vou ao banheiro quando eu quero é
fabrício
pois é fabrício concorda então gente
olha a gente precisa tratar esse assunto
com naturalidade pra gente poder agir
também com naturalidade senão fica
aquele china pela coisa cheia de nuances
a criança quando a pergunta é como eu
nasci aí começam olha foi uma plantinha
uma sementinha você ficou pendurado a
gente já imagina uma criança pendurada a
lista do aguardo gente isso claro muita
gente já não faz mais
mas muita gente ainda anda por aí
falando de coisas que às vezes eu mesmo
não consigo entender que a minhoca no
seu que o moranguinho cef
não vamos falar a verdade direto do
assunto fica tudo certo a criança vai
entender
eles entendem nós subestimamos uma outra
coisa é a gente começar a tratá los como
gente grande
se eles forem grande não ficar tratando
como a criança que nunca cresceu
vestindo roupa de bebê ou de criança
quando ele já são grande
aí fica parecendo o kiko do chaves nesta
botafogo pb
então tem que começar pelas pequenas
coisas pelas pequenas coisas e começar a
tratar de acordo com a idade dele e aí
vocês automaticamente já vão começar a
pensar nas coisas que vocês têm para
falar e que não vai chocar né então
gente eu acho que a melhor coisa é a
gente esquecer a vergonha esqueceu
preconceito e se livrar dessa angústia
isso não pode mais ser uma angústia e é
o que eu mais ouço do consultório então
por exemplo o trabalho com o grupo de
mães na hora que a gente está fazendo a
palestra tô falando alguma coisa elas
ouvem fazem perguntas tal mas na hora de
falar sobre sexualidade
aí eu quero falar uma coisa
você depois eu já sei a even sexo né
eu quero falar uma coisa e vai lá entre
quatro paredes bem escondidinha de porta
fechada aí o meu filho tá fazendo isso
atirando pra fora não sei o quê
então gente não vamos mais fugir disso
não tá se é natural vão aceitar eu acho
que fica até mais leve
eu passei aqui bem rapidinho só para dar
leveza a esse assunto eu gostaria agora
de lição de casa pra vocês é o seguinte
é pensar em ficar no ar assim pra vocês
pensaram é justo a gente tirar da
criança e do adolescente o prazer
olha a palavra o prazer de conhecer o
próprio corpo
se a gente também faz isso né
então é isso